a natural disaster has once again
devastated Haiti a country that is yet
to recover from the massive earthquake
of 2010 that quake killed hundreds of
thousands and displaced 1.5 million
people inspiring many to action Obama
wanted to help Sean Penn wanted to help
even I donated $10 via text billions of
dollars of international aid poured in
to the people of Haiti in this your hour
of greatest need America stands with you
so today you must know that help is
arriving good to go right wrong six
years later tens of thousands of
Haitians still lived in tent encampments
even before this latest hurricane hit
and Haiti remains the poorest country in
the Western Hemisphere completely
dependent on the more than 10,000 NGOs
that operate there with so much aid
pouring in from the US and abroad where
did things go wrong
as of 2014 the US had distributed a
majority of its promised funds to Haiti
half of which were given to USAID but
here's the thing
most of that USAID money went to
American contractors hired to do work in
Haiti rather than Haitians themselves
that means a lot of that money paid for
American salary supplies and travel
leaving little for actual rebuilding the
same can be said for other relief
organizations like the Red Cross which
collected nearly half a billion dollars
in donations much of that from $10
text-message pledges by American
citizens but the Red Cross refused to
provide a breakdown of detailed costs
and it's not clear where all that money
actually ended up which leads us to
reason to both the Red Cross and USAID
had trouble fulfilling promises to build
permanent housing the Red Cross claims
to have provided housing for more than
130,000 people but the number of
permanent homes they actually ended up
building 6 both organizations say they
were denied land write contracts from
the Haitian government which is a whole
other roadblock to recovery in itself
and then there's those who see potential
profits and others devastation one case
was the development of the caracal
industrial park in northern Haiti a 300
million dollar project funded in part by
the Clinton Foundation and we believe
that our work here in Haiti and here in
the north is beginning to show results
the project was supposed to create
60,000 to 100,000 new haitian jobs but
the actual number of jobs it created
5,400 79o and these weren't meaningful
skills for rebuilding the country they
were garment factory jobs like stitching
underwear for target for years Haiti has
been largely reliant on international
aid for food vaccinations clean water
and shelter it's ineffective and corrupt
government has failed to invest in
education medical clinics and
self-sustaining infrastructure and it
has a long history of election
interference by none other than the
United
Hades last president Michelle sweet
Mickey Martelly a former pop singer only
gained presidency after the u.s. got
involved and it doesn't help that Hades
had an interim president since February
and elections have already been delayed
for nearly a year when it comes to
helping out our poorest neighbor the
u.s. screwed up big-time so what will it
actually take to help Haiti get back on
its own two feet
[Music]